Trump's attorney rudy giuliani says he
will not testify before the house Intel
committee until there's been a formal
impeachment vote and its chairman Adam
Schiff is removed well into the void
swoop Senator Lindsey Graham he's
invited Giuliani to testify before the
Senate Judiciary Committee about
possible corruption in Ukraine so is
Giuliani to accept this offer back we've
now Rudy Giuliani showed to Genova Rudy
you know testify in the Senate I have to
weigh that with my client and the other
lawyers involved it's not a it's not a
unitary decision what decision I made
may affect the other decisions I mean I
would love to testify and give me a half
hour to point out Biden Inc for decades
of crime I love to do it I mean it's
gonna be easier than pointing out the
what was it six decades of mafia crime
or milk in a bowl ski what was that what
was going on with Perry everybody's all
upset about that work he works for
Donald he was at the inauguration of
Lansky oh my goodness yeah he was there
and Senator Chris Murphy when it tolls
the Lewinsky he better not cooperate
with me had a couple of other senators
called him to don't cooperate was bar
and nobody cares about that did you
debrief him after the trap before I'm
not going to tell you my internal
conversations I talk to a lot of people
not necessarily Rick though Rudy Cory
Booker is someone who also is chomping
at the bit to question you during the
hearing support occurs this is what he
said Spartacus I would savor the
opportunity I would and especially if
it's done publicly and I know Rudy
Giuliani is now from New York very close
to Broadway he loves the theatrics this
behavior has been despicable and the
lies and half-truths
and the deception that he's been doing
at the direction of this president and
beyond is unbecoming unbecoming
despicable just garden-variety insults
Rudi that some I gotta go I have to go
in the arena with Spartacus she I don't
know if I can handle it and he's a
really tough guy I don't know man he
really scares me
the guy was a terrible mayor my was a
mayor of the city I turned it around he
was a better City and they had more
crime when he left them when he came in
networks doing great it's not oh yeah
gooks doing fabulous here's looked up to
Cory Booker everyone's a tough guy out
there right they're all worried she's
gonna take him and punch him by let's
get it border crews by the way Biden's
been off the trail 4.0 since what cried
a never see bye all right I just see
biting today he completely lost it today
he completely lost it today he started
yelling at a reporter first it looked
like he was sleeping
absolutely today I think in Las Vegas
all right gentlemen the sources told the
Washington Examiner spire in New York
about the whistleblower quote the IG
said the whistleblower had a
professional relationship with one of
the 20 20 candidates okay Joe this turns
out to be true doesn't you know isn't
the Democrats keeping his or her
identity secret total joke that this is
why this notion that you're gonna keep
these witnesses secret while you were
trying to nullify an election yeah
exactly mitt regicide and remove a
President of the United States is
ludicrous everybody knows that in all
likelihood fusion GPS was involved with
this person this this anonymous
informant I refused to call him a
whistleblower because he is not a
whistleblower under the law and
everybody knows that there's a former
FBI agent work who worked with this
whistleblower as he's now called so
we're gonna learn an awful lot about the
fact that this person never wrote this
document it was drafted by a committee
of political consultants and researchers
and people affiliated with the
Democratic National Committee
well Adam Schiff should not be running
this in this thing these please he lied
about contact with this
some lower he's a national television he
just lied out of [ __ ] as a witness you
can't you can't preside over a hearing
where you're a witness now also how how
could it be possible that we can't test
the credibility of these witnesses I
mean you can't you can't come to a
conclusion unless you get a chance to
test credibility for example this law
firm Campos Dumbo's or whatever the name
of it is was offering money to people
they were offering help with your
mortgage expenses they were robbing
their witnesses to come forward you
don't think I'd want to cross-examine
the witness with that did you read the
did you read it did you get any money
did they offer you anybody did you see
shift
what did Schiff tell you how much how
much of this comes from sure these were
shouldn't have to be changed all right
they have to be this this can't happen
again way but this whistle boys here's
the deal this inspector general is a
[ __ ] when he wrote that analysis he was
wrong about the law this was not a
matter of grave concern urgent concern
he got slapped down so badly by the
office of legal counsel when they
analyzed the facts this guy Michael
Atkinson is a [ __ ] just there's no way
around how bad a job he did he's an
embarrassment to the inspector general
cadre well now we know that there is a
20/20 connection 20/20 democrat
connection to this whistleblower
and by the way someone tried to
criticize or question byron new york's
reporting tonight and even i believe was
a taxi Oh said no no it was just fine
he's right on Byron New York is spot on
it's reporting about this well so we're
gonna learn a lot and it's gonna get
worse
yeah well today Rudy the State
Department ordered Gordon Sandlin the EU
ambassador involved in some of those
Ukraine texts not to appear for his
deposition with house investigators
which of course it kind of makes sense
given simple oneis letter right which of
course is drawing the ire of chef's
watch the failure to produce this
witness the failure to produce these
documents we consider yet additional
strong evidence of obstruction of the
constitutional functions of Congress a
co-equal
branch of government okay if you assert
a privilege seriously if you assert a
privilege executive privilege return to
client privilege deliberative process
privilege you are guilty of obstruction
of justice so there's there's no winning
in this cellulite I just like to explain
to little shift that propounding and
presenting a false completely false
narrative someone's guilt
it's called obstructing justice he did
it he did it right in front of the
American people he did it for about 20
minutes he did a total fictitious claim
against and he did it again earlier when
he said he had evidence of Russian
collusion Hey Schiff where's your
evidence and thereby they're a liar I'm
calling you out as a liar you're a liar
and by there's your evidence shift
they're hitting sunland by the way of
course you're a liar they're hitting
sunland ambassador's son because he was
a big donor to Trump I'm thinking does
anyone remember what Obama's donors were
okay I'm a bama's donors I mean there
was headline after headline complaining
I think put one up on the screen but
Obama's big that's that's just what it
is a yes sir unless you're a career a
career diplomat Obama hands out plum
ambassador post a big campaign donors to
stop stop going after someone because he
was a donor if if it weren't for double
standards Democrats would have no
standards at all that's just insanity
just watching him get that tape of shift
just watching him bug-eyed performing
like a loon and just mouthing these
nostrils which were just just dumb and
stupid and unsupportable legally I mean
this is the chairman of a major
committee and Pelosi you know trying to
keep her dentures in while she's talking
to him it's just there
abiding by this it's outrageous it
really and it would be funny if it
wasn't a horrible horrible trashing of
our Constitution yeah and that has
repercussions repercussions because it
keeps our country bitter divided they
think everybody thinks like them they
don't they're a lot of talk a lot of
people are living their life
they really bitter about what these
people are doing I want to end with what
Pat Cipollone II wrote at toward the end
of his letter great the president has a
country to lead the American people
elected him to do his job do this job
and he remains focused on fulfilling his
promises to the American people he has
important work that must continue on
their behalf both at home and around the
world people can laugh like Oh Kurt you
know you were upset about the car I get
people are upset about the curse these
are us MCA infrastructure all these
things are really important and the
safety and security of our country he
has to keep doing the people's business
they don't want him to do them they
wouldn't they want to paralyze this and
I'm rooting out high-level corruption is
enormous Lee we're gonna learn how we
confident you are and then act the next
couple weeks we're gonna know a lot more
from from Horowitz Durham and the rest
this is gonna be bang bang a couple of
weeks incandescent ignoramus to me okay
everyone's tweeting about incandescent
anger let's get that trending tonight on
Twitter Rudy and Joe both of you thanks
so much